et puis un pont entre deux communautés à
mostar la reconstruction du vieux-pont
symbole aussi de ce retour à la paix un
pont qui avait été détruit par les
croates et ce sont les européens qui
aujourd'hui recolle les morceaux
reportage de pascal verre d'eau et
pierre alterman c'est une ville dont le
prince est un enfant bosniaques une
ville qui possédait un vieux pont du 16e
siècle véritable joyau de l'empiré
ottoman stary most le vieux disaient les
habitants de mostar le vieux témoins des
joies et des rêves d'une cité au
carrefour des cultures stary most visé
au coeur il y a quatre ans
et pourtant dit une chanson ils étaient
solides comme un os ce sont nos frères à
la barbe noire qu'ils ont détruit alors
avec le même acharnement chaque jour les
sapeurs hongrois de la sfor la force de
stabilisation en bosnie s'efforce de
repêcher des vestiges du pont ce jour là
dans les eaux glacées de la neretva les
plongeurs ont trouvé une petite pierre
de 8 tonnes nouveaux morceaux de base
avant reconstitution s'est taillé
routine qui a construit le pont nous
dira fièrement yasmine le petit orphelin
mémoire d'un pays enfance volée regardez
on a bouché les trous du plafond comme
on a pu lorsque les obus tombés on se
couchait sur le sol en serrant les
enfants ils ont huit ans mais il joue
encore aujourd'hui avec des peluches de
petits de 3 ans la guerre les a privés
de leur enfance reconstruire avec l'aide
de l'union européenne des écoles des
rues des hôpitaux mostar est presque
redevenu une ville normale mais comment
reconstruire une confiance entre les
deux rives entre croates et musulmans au
point c'était mon rêve
une ville ouverte à tous les peuples une
ville où les enfants pourront jouer en
soirée comme à davos
c'est peut-être ici à mostar que se joue
l'avenir du processus de paix en bosnie
herzégovine mais c'est sûrement ici
autour de la reconstruction du vieux
pont le star i must que se joue une
certaine idée de l'europe la tolérance